okay so this is our standard right
you're on a flat table flat piece of
paper whatever resolve the forces okay
so you can see this is a simpler one
because all I have is the tension in the
string that's the only thing that's
giving me weird kind of forces right
I've got the normal here off the table
but I don't have to resolve it because
it's just up and down and then of course
there's a weight force which easy no
matter result right so you can see same
thing down the bottom here I will just
make a brief comment right after you've
gone ahead and resolve this and you'll
see this happens a lot by the way all
conical pendulums are pretty much set up
in the same way and it just sort of
makes sense to always have this city
vertex angle is the one that we use
because it's like well okay well then we
can take advantage of the same idea
every time you're going to get this
flipped around thing where your
horizontal one is sine and your vertical
one is cosine once you put them together
easier equations now I just want you to
note this we try and we've I hope I've
modeled this for you well right every
time you see an equation you get to it
like a simplified spot or something like
that you should then say well what does
that mean right now what I like about
this is that this tells you for instance
if you've got like that Soubirous we had
those strings and we're spinning things
around okay if you have it exactly
exactly taut right there is some tension
in the string and there is some force
that's being reactive from the table or
whatever service you're wrong okay and
if you start to let go of the string
right that's this component over here
this is what's coming from the tension
of the string okay so if you're relaxing
that remember it's this thing on the
table presumably the mass that you're
speeding around good morning it's not so
heavy that you know it's gonna make up
press the hole through the table okay
so presumably it's still stationary
which means that these two sides have to
remain balanced does that make sense
well if this is getting smaller then
this must get bigger right well imagine
if the mass was on your hand
okay and you've got the string holding
up there as you relax the string you
will feel more weight your hand is doing
the lifting rather than the stream this
is fix it so these guys always have to
add up to this so this has to increase
okay so each one is pushing its own
amount in auditor
to the wait okay so that was my that was
my explanation there you can see here it
is somewhat trivial you're like yeah
it's headed towards the center and
that's also headed toward the center but
this is going to be you'll see this is a
preferred way either the solutions or
you know a question which says prove
that the forces done or not because just
less negatives so why not but I still
like to write this because this is where
it comes from
this means motion toward the center it's
somewhat coincidental but they're just
oriented in the same way okay as you see
it's not always the case let's have a
look this is the one we just did let me
make a comment hopefully you see this on
this diagram and you've looked at yours
we talked about the colors that you use
and what can you see in what can't be
I'm very deliberately on all of these
diagrams meant to show you I've only
used the approved colors black and blue
just so that your diagram doesn't get
too busy right I like to just by
convention I like to make the actual
motion a special color and then the rest
of the diagram I've got in it just so I
can see this is where all the action is
happening right so I seen it it's
different and put in right angles where
they're relevant yeah
I I think I think it's fine to be honest
I think it's fine because remember this
is mainly about you interpret your own
diagram right and being able to form all
this stuff like this is in black and
blue and that's not negotiable but what
you do over here that's fine but if
you're if you're like oh no but it has
to be like I'm saying this is under the
most limited situation and you can still
have enough color gear to distinguish
what's going on alright now if you have
a look at see here's the question and
inverted cone and inverted cone okay so
what's different and what's the same
well this this is almost always going to
be the same right that tin ship I've
still got all the same equations to set
up when you have a look at the normal
force because your code is upside down
look at the direction that the normal
force is facing you see that so in fact
the normal force and the tension force
are more or less oriented in the same
way except they're just off by an angle
okay that angle again is two because
it's a normal force it's defined by the
angle of this surface right you just
didn't right angles to whatever that is
right and so that's why here you can see
both of my arm resolution diagram you
can see attention off to up and left
normal also up to the top and left but I
had to draw this part in here which
corresponds to always with this alpha
where is it coming from right so that I
can do my ankles in here properly yeah
and then again you combine them key see
what's happened you see what's happened
these guys they're both positive because
they both headed that way and both of
these they're negative because they're
both headed that way into the center
okay let's have a look another example
here we go hi this is in fact I think
the example I showed you last week I
mentioned it I think we didn't do
anything with it on the surface of a
sphere
okay in fact you'll find it's pretty
much just like this one it's pretty much
just like this one with one difference
can you see have a look at this one just
forget that the circle is there for a
moment or the speedo rather just just do
this
okay yeah the only difference is where
offer is right the forces are still
oriented in the same directions tensions
still gone that way
normal still going this way ah but now
this measures from down here okay which
means when you come down to here
these guys have swapped around do you
see that so you just gotta be careful
with weird that's why I don't skimp on
this don't try and do it in your head
drawing draw where the complementary
angles are in fact you can see here I've
just use alternate angles it's super
easy if you take the time to draw a good
diagram okay I better put that sphere
back otherwise my diagram is militarily
let's get going have a look at this one
inside of the bowl inside of all right
this is just like the upside down the
inverted cone okay
but again just have a look at where
you're measuring your angle from before
they measure the angle at the tip of the
cone which is at the bottom but here is
the sphere right so they're going to
measure the important point for a sphere
is the very center so that's why the end
goes in there and you can see just
compare this to what we did over here
right have a look at what some actually
sorry this is not we want to come here
let me make a bit smaller so you can see
at the top there we go okay so you can
see what's different it's going to be
each time what varies is how do these
science relate right
and what about these angles is it cosine
or as if sine based on where ever
they're measuring from right and all
you're doing is just shuffling it around
it all depends on your construction of
these diagrams okay I think I've got to
illustrate two or three
here we go okay ah this is in a moment
so I think Raph you mentioned this one
before this is a single string passing
from A to B right and then they'll say
piers something like a smooth light ring
okay so therefore it just binds it along
in a Miss thing moves around okay the
important thing is and you can if you
have your string that actually not did
you take your strings home with you
was it Brendan who I only taught he's
apart don't don't just imagine this
actually get you piece of string out
right if you get a friend to hold this
here for you right and then you've got
these ends well if you pull on one end
you're pulling on the other end too
right so if you pull here you'll let go
at this end if you're not holding it
properly okay so what that means is
these two tensions have to remain the
same right you pull her it's not like
it's going to be on there's a stretchy
part of the stream and a non stretchy
part pulling here necessarily he's
really here which is why these are equal
ah no it does it because I can move this
up and down so it doesn't have to be
like these are equal in length that's
right so yeah if that makes sense but
the total tension will be equal okay and
the angles the angles will make these
things different to each other so again
you have a look you'll start to get very
tired of see these same kinds of
equations right why do you go to be
careful this where are the sides which
is between these facing all depends on
this and which one is cosine which one
is science so you're just got to be very
careful at your positioning of your
angle okay G is not really worth looking
at okay I think this is the last one so
again single stream right but this time
you've got two masses right to medicine
so one is the one that's swinging around
and the other one is the one that's kind
of like an anchor sort of right because
it's the one stream that's why you can
see these guys they're equal right and
then you're just going to be careful
with I came away the forces going now
despite the seeming complexity of these
like although there's two masses okay
because this guy isn't moving right
it's the end car right it's not moving
up or down so these two just balance
each other and it's not moving left all
right well that's good because there's
no forces acting like left or right so
you don't have to worry about any of
those so you resolve the port the forces
at paint that's just full and then you
get those equations when you're doing a
cue that's it it seems complicated but
it's not so don't get intimidated by all
right so I guess my tip is what makes us
different from projectile is that it's
you've got to worry about your
directions but once you do you'll like
just do all of these and you'll start to
get a vibe for them ah this is a lot it
will feel different every time for the
first two or three and then you will get
into a rhythm okay